("Discoplosion")
- Hi, my name is Sylvia Yoo.
I'm the chef and owner of Churro Burrough
here in Los Angeles.
This has been a project
long in the making.
I have gone to culinary school in New York
and came back to Los
Angeles and decided that
instead of working in another restaurant
I wanted to do something for myself.
So for me I thought of it more like
what are components that
go really well together.
A lot of times you want
something that's warm,
and cold and something with texture.
Something that's smooth.
So kind of digging into my
memories and things like that,
the churro kind of came up in my head
more often than once.
It has that crispy
factor, that flaky factor,
has a lightness to it, but
a heaviness to it as well,
and it balances and pairs
really well with ice cream.
("Discoplosion")
So one day I decided to make
some churros for my family
and decided to put a
scoop of ice cream on it
and it tasted really good.
And after weeks and months
of research and development
the churro ice cream sandwich came about.
We make everything in house,
a small batch from scratch.
And it really ensures the quality
and the freshness of what we do.
("Discoplosion")